hello everyone and welcome to today's
hit series webinars advanced optical
hematology technology for elevated
analytical performance I'm Christie
jewel of lab routes and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminars presented by
laberd's and brought to you by Abbott
Diagnostics to learn more about our
sponsor visit Abbott com
now before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation now if you have any
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or you can report
your problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located at the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational invest offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credit I now present today's
speaker dr. Zeynep
Mukhtar manager medical and scientific
affairs Abbott hematology for a complete
biography on our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen
dr. mops are you may now begin your
presentation
thank you for the introduction I would
like to welcome you today on the today's
web series of the webinar on advanced
optical technology for the elevated
analytical performance this speaker
program is sponsored by and on behalf of
other diagnostic and the content of this
presentation is consistent with all the
applicable FDA requirements
coming to the topic hematology analyzers
are available from multiple
manufacturers and employing different
detection methods today I will discuss
the general principles of optical
technology and how it improve
cellular analysis and overcome the
limitations commonly seen with impedance
I will proceed forward with the
introduction of LED S series and explain
the advanced snap technology describing
the analytical approach for the white
blood cells platelets with ourselves and
reticulocyte with relevant phase
demonstration
the LED f series of systems integrates
climatology Berg flow from the
high-throughput completes that found
analysis to automated side making and
scaling
it is currently available as a
stand-alone analyzer and also as an
integrated system with a slightly
current cana the system offers a
solution to many of the struggles faced
by the laboratory to focus on the system
reliability delivering a high throughput
of 119 CBC's per hour for alyttle HQ
system having 197 CBC's per meter square
which is one of the highest throughput
on the market with full integration of
the analyzer and the slide maker and
stainer to reduce london intervention
the three region and the bulk solution
which simplifies reagent management
providing the complete 6 card
differential and the reticulocyte found
with continuous loading of the reagents
in small volume containers for
uninterrupted operation along with the
robust middleware solution to harmonize
laboratory operation for higher
productivity
well coming to the technology as a glam
the enemy THC technology uses flow
cytometry which is based on the optical
light shuttle system with fluorescence
from an alignment free optics range to
deliver a six-part differential the
years of the Sorensen nuclear diet
allows for the distinction of the
nucleated IDC and resistant RBC and look
an inclusion of the nucleated algae
seeds with every CBC intervention
incorporating the light scattering
principles based on the mid series and
using approximation algorithms the red
blood cells are identified in terms of
cell by cell volume removing the
limitations of impedance analyzers in
coincidence and volume measurements by
also providing cell by cell hemoglobin
concentration the reticulocyte algorithm
and the dye on the LM TF series allows
for the reticulated sweetness to be
included with every reticular site
analysis
I can remove that electrical impedance
was the first automated technology to
counsel and also to measure the size of
the white blood cells red blood cells
and platelets
the sweater is based on the measurement
of changes in the electric current which
was produced by the particle suspended
in the conductive liquid as it passes
through an aperture
as the particle process sugar purchase
the transitionary change in the
resistance between the electrodes is
could used and is measured to determine
the number of particles and their
associated cordial one of the
difficulties associated with the
impedance wave cell measurements is
controlling the white blood cells and
the other cells from irregular free
circulation in and around the detection
zone of the aperture this interference
or duplication of signals by the same
cells require correction for impedance
this could be result fixed the
correction polina however there was no
way to correct the volume measurement by
simply applying the coin series
connection of two cells which are
passing through the sensing zone close
to the wall of the posture with a
high-density electric current exists
with the introduction of the
hydrodynamic focusing it allowed the
ordinary passage of cells for sensing
zone and the automated hematology
technology were able to advance through
the optics based methods for the cell
fertilization and counting these
alliances were then passing through an
optical interrogation point the light
signals are generated from each passing
service different angles giving
information about the cell size internal
structure granularity and surface
morphology
additionally applications like citations
of staining or fluorescence may be
combined with optics to provide an
additional information regarding the
cell population
coming to the Maps technology math
stands for multi angle polarized scatter
separations switches advert spacing
technology a limit e HK uses an advanced
version of maps technology with three
additional light scatter detectors as
you can see in this figure a focused
laser beam is scattered by the cells
moving through the flow cells the
detectors on the energy measures the
light sector in several different
directions and use it to identify the
cells this works in conjunction with the
falsest detector to provide the complete
that sound
first angle we would like to discuss is
the a ll it is you to determine the size
of the cell
second angle is the 90 licking or the
light except that is detected by the
polarized side setter this provides
information about the nuclear
segmentation the third angle is the set
of detectors that make up the
intermediate sites kappa the eliminated
series have four detectors that are set
between two point five and seven point
five degrees and these angles measure
the internal complexity of the cell
giving an idea about the volume similar
in content and granulation these angles
also help to differentiate large
placeless from small orbits and red
blood cells the mast angle is the
depolarized ninety degrees light scatter
or the depolarize side scatter like the
polar ice ice cutter it is placed at 90
degrees but instead of the polarized
light it is looking for the D polarized
light and this is important to identify
the presence of granules like those that
are found in here it
the exhaust / a street light scatter and
salsa cellular signature measurement are
represented on this light as you can see
in the table it displays the list of the
various data angles and qualities
detection
what's a broadly measure and which
methods the application it is used the
exit light loss measures the cell size
the new array of the included angle
scatter detectors measure and provide
information ranging from the sent
complexity to the red blood cells
platelets and reticulated hemoglobin
along with the Phi's information the
polarized light scattered constitute
nuclear segmentation the depolarized
side scatter provide information
specific for user films and the
fluorescence
fl1 measure the forces at 530 nanometers
which quantifies the salsas intensity
from the nucleic acid positive gaming
characteristics of the girls in question
the Elemental HQ reports 29 measuring
which are shown on this screen then it
is run in the CPC practice century plus
particular side mode the rate only
results are immature logic no side
fraction me coffee is a Maclaurin of
particular sign particular size
concentration and percentage along with
this the nucleated RBC's and regulated
platelets are also available with every
CBC and differential result
the parameter of the main coffee spoon
hemoglobin of particular size is also
reported it has proven to be a good
predictor in the iron deficiency anemia
in several studies as it's known
compared with a little size the shorter
lifespan of particular size make this
parameter a better biomarker to deflect
iron status in the short term it also
gives a snapshot of the iron
availability or electrophoresis
this table lists the morphology slides
on the LNT edge cubes in the presence of
the platelets lamp last and the variant
limb profile
most labs will perform a smear review no
further actions are necessary in the
case of the left shift slash
however each laboratory will make that
decision based on their internal
procedures note that the plated clamps
life can also indicate large great place
in the presence of the RTC slides
fragrance lags most labs will make a
smear and will perform the smear review
however no further action such as
correcting the white blood cells numbers
is necessary in the case of analyzed red
blood cells as yourself do not interfere
with the WBC number in the case of the
hemoglobin interference line it is
recommended to visually inspect the
specimens as the flag can be triggered
by light premios analysis and it can
also be triggered in the case of four
samples or in the presence of God
I'm now to see it forward and talk about
the energy HPD's analyzable approach for
the white blood cells and I will
demonstrate some cases
we know that there are various
approaches that have been adapted by the
hematology analyzers by losing optical
laser in Traulsen technology either
having multiple channels for the white
blood cell analysis with various regions
of different light intensities modular
approaches of choosing sequential mode
of analysis while adapting different
techniques of reducing interferences
which are mainly from the resistance red
blood cells giant platelets which may
lead to the curiously low absolutely
high now the enema THU design is unique
because it has a simpler one channel
approach that illuminates simulated red
blood cells it's every complete
background result the white blood cell
free agent contains the nucleic acid
selected smallish and cationic dye that
same filling click acid and choruses the
reagent removes the cytoplasmic membrane
from the red blood cells and then the
nucleated RBC's are present expose
nuclei are then stained by the dye and
they also float it
the WC membranes are intact and are
permeated by the same therefore leave
notices as well this can be busy reagent
permits to distinguish white red cells
from the light resistant red blood cells
the NADH ki enumerates the nucleated red
blood cells with every complete
background and differential result also
inclusion of the additional lights get
the angles that we discussed before and
the algorithm allows for the enumeration
of immature granule size concentrate and
percentage element a report a six-part
WC differential which includes the
images when you fight concentration and
percentage and along with that the
nucleated RBC's are also coated as
concentration and number 100 white blood
cells they do not interfere with the WBC
count there is no connection of the WBC
concentration is required even if the
nucleated RBC's are present
- I chose the white blood cell
differential scatterplot as you can see
on the left the first one is the ll
versus the PSS scatter plot it is the
sine versus the polarized light scatter
it shows the distance which we segmented
and the unsegmented cells which are poly
and mono nuclear cells the second one
below is the scatter plot which is of
the internal complexity versus the size
is versus being ll it separates the
major components of the junction as you
can see here the top one is a polarized
five scatter versus the depolarize side
scatter plot the scatter is most useful
for seeing you know kills and in this
scatter the Urals which are shown in
green are differentiated from
neutrophils by their unique ability to
depolarize 90 degree light due to the
granules inside the cells and the last
one below on the right if the
fluorescence versus a ll fluorescence
versus the side plot which displays the
nucleated red blood cells then they are
present they are colored red in the
lower right hand area based on their
small size and highly fluorescent
intensity
something about the resistant RBC's here
as it is known the increase resistance
of the red blood cell to myself it's
very comforting and sometimes also
physiologically in the new name in the
premature baby and sometimes in certain
hemoglobinopathies however this
interference the LMC h qs does not
impact the white blood cell count as you
can see the scatter plots also they are
clearly identified and shows valid
results in the first analysis it has a
higher false pass efficiency and this
little red blood cell identification in
hematology analyzers have proven to be
diagnostic in many studies
here we will talk about the nucleated
rate that sells in this case we will
focus on the white best self analysis
so this station presents a complex case
with Yuka cytosis with absolutely
lophelia and the high neutrophil count
of 86 percent of the dissension there is
a left shift slide and it indicates the
high number of families Russell's
immature when the fight and nucleated
RBC's are also present and they are
found separately the manual essentially
found a high percentage of the band
neutrophils in violet electric slide the
number of signatures on your side's
which are meta modified Milo fights and
promyelocytes seen on the sphere is
consistent with Ellen THQ count the
manual and automated you created redness
cell counts also agreed importantly a
Lilla T can be searched when you create
a district cell from the white blood
cells and count them separately so there
is no need to correct the vibrates and
count for the presence of the nucleated
red blood cells and new credited blood
cells do not interfere with the white
blood cell analysis
this kind of a serious table etiology
czar possibly for example hemolysis
hemoglobinopathies former acute bleeding
my little easier on leukemia
looking at the scatter plots it's
interesting to see the differential
scatter plot based on the five versus
the intermediate angle light scatter
shows the nucleated RBC's engraved in
the lower left portion of the block
and we are separated from all the other
non WBC events which you can see in
grades and they do not interfere in the
WBC differential analysis so no
correction of the WBC count is required
till early in this set of thought
comparing a nucleated RBC phase with the
normal sample looking at the solution
versus the size it measure the
fluorescence signal versus the size of
the very the nucleated RBC population in
drink is located in the lower right
portion of the plot due to their small
size and high 4s and intensities this
population is normally not present in
the sample with the exception of the
newborn specially prematurely born in
home when you created our disease may be
physiologically present so the result is
that when you created our disease do not
interfere in the WBC found in any of the
edge here
it makes the completeness count to those
chose leukocytosis that absolute
neutrophilia immature valuable size and
the next ship flag with a high immature
wrangle size count the let ships like in
disease the presence of band neutrophils
and it's important to note that it does
not invalidate the results
the manager changes found a high
percentage of the family tokens
consistent with the left ship flag and
the number of immature well known size
which are meta magnified smile size and
Romero 5b numbers near agreed with the
annuity HQ immature values I found such
a situation of the neutrophilic left
shift slide with immature Daniel size is
a relatively common finding it is more
chocolate oh she ate it with infections
information malignancy particularly the
minor pro-life ages neoplasm such as
chronic - Isaac leukemia
now we will proceed forward to look at
the analyzable approach of salinity edge
for the Reds ourselves and create
analysis and even discuss some cases
prior to the analysis for the red blood
cells the deccan cells are filled to
remove the orientation effect of the red
blood cells when they are measured in
the optical detection system as you can
see in the thinner
normally the red blood cells are by
continuity formable disk fifty a
biconcave by changing the surface
tension the red blood cells can be
transformed into spheres with unchanged
detectable volume and then the
measurement signal is produced in the
flow cell is no longer affected by the
cell orientation
directed self-placement and associated
measurements on ability our process from
the optical light capture information
using various tackle figures the removal
of the searing effects and multiple
angles of the light scatter enable
better separation of the Redcat cells
from Caithness additionally the nth key
also measures the red crest cells volume
on cell by cell phases based on the mood
theory of light chakra as you can see in
the figure the visor angle intermediate
angle scatter measurements also provide
cell by cell hemoglobin concentration
increases the mean capital emo globin of
particular size is also available when
the retic analysis is performed
so what are the benefits of this
multi-dimensional analysis let's look at
the benefits of multi-dimensional
analysis are best seen when the pay
person's
RBC's are of similar in size and such
situations are present in the presence
of my pathetic RBC's RBC fragments large
or giant cases in these cases impedance
or dual angle light shutter technology
may demonstrate the signal overlap using
the multi-dimensional analysis the
different measurement angles of the
light scatter produces unique signal
signatures even when the patriots and
their crest cells are of same size so we
know now that it is possible to achieve
the accuracy of the basic counting in
optical methods they disapprove
however in some analyzers they still
need extra channel extra reagent we
should not only reduce the turnaround
time but they also increase the cost
here we will discuss something related
to the red card cell signal a
significant finding regarding the red
button indicates a parameter it's the
RDP fragment fly the presence of which
has rendered the red blood cell and the
basic sounds and associated parameters
in this case suspect as you can see
highlighted in red this case is
presented with Amelia along with the low
hemoglobin hematocrit and low RBC count
with a high MCC as you can see along
with this there is any so cytosis in the
high RDW
and the ridiculous size concentration is
high and the percentage is 4.8 the plane
the smear reviews also found the mild
increase in body from Asia and a little
fighter is consistent with the elevated
regular site found and in created breast
cell distribution width is quite evident
this layer also relieves a moderate
number of 55 it amplifies ember cells
but this mayor also confirmed the end in
dhq plate that comes
now looking at the scatter plot of this
changes and comparing it with a normal
sample you can see that the presence of
the RBC segments are seen in the
intermediate angle scatter worlds's the
size dot and the intermediate angle
scattered teal and the scatter three
o'clock also clearly shows the overlap
along the x-axis between the red blood
cells and the platelets after suggesting
the presence of the red blood cell
segments that are similar in size to the
platelet however the next lesson the
created populations are clearly
separated along the y axis and this is
because of the result of differences in
their internal complexity and the light
scatter characteristics so it is
important to note that the
multi-dimensional analysis of the
platelets which we discussed before
allows this separation in most of the
circumstances presenting the problems
encountered in impedance based
hematology analyzers we're squeezing
High Council creatives can be seen in
such situations
this is another very interesting case of
the great desk lamp
we will focus on the plate rate clamp
slide in this case as you can see that
the glacier clamp flag is pressing and
it results in an invalidated cryptic
count and associated parameters the
smear review confirms the presence of
the moderate number of variably sized
paper comes the patron count is normal
in this case as you can see but it is
not yet portable because it does not
include the pixels that are clamped
the patient also has a normal form
economist attorney Mia and the
scattergram shows great platelet clamps
which are clearly differentiated from
the white blood cells and they do not
interfere in the white blood cell
analysis something that already analyzes
still are unable to detect this and they
show for
leukocytosis you to the platelets clump
which are large enough to mimic divide
the cell size
looking at the scatter plots of this
particular case and comparing it with a
normal one it shows a collector istic
pattern that is specific to the cryptid
camp the positioning of the pasted clamp
and then emphasized population along the
a and L X X's forget that their size is
similar however using the polar right
side scatter on the y axis the two
populations are separated and there is
no interference with the white blood
cell count or detention results
similarly if you see below in the to
scatter plot which is of the soliton
versus a file you can see that they are
clearly separated so the class of here
is separated from the WBC and
essentially and they do not interfere in
the WBC and differential analysis
I proceed now to discuss the
reticulocytes analytical approach of a
little HCV and I will discuss a case
about it
this figure as you can see on the slides
is an interesting scatterplot
representing molecular size measurement
the x-axis is the relative size is on
the exeunt light loss measurement and
the Y is a green fluorescence it feels
positive for the presence of the nucleic
acid the basic reagent uses uses of
lonesome guide that bind to the RNA
found in the original size can ever be
ordered ethics on the instrument and any
course is taken from the RBC and paper
dilution algorithm for septic the red
blood cells from the white blood cells
and platelets based on the sides and
choruses intensity if then differentiate
furniture are the field from the high
solacing reticular side using a dynamic
threshold
also with the second dynamic threshold
it's kept great the immature
reticulocyte fraction with highest
policy intensity from the maturity
column size as you can see here the
mature platelets in yellow are also
separated from the immature reticulated
creatures that are highlighted in blue
and this particular retinal type method
also allows the energy s series to
display the meal composition hemoglobin
of particular size it is also a very
important parameter
now looking at this case of the increase
tetrachloride concentration and how it
is demonstrated this patient has a
normal form economic side egg anemia
with low-grade blood cells hemoglobin
and hematocrit and the nucleated algae
C's are also present
the biceps cell count is high along with
this there is no platelets with
increased number of reticulated
pre-clear the sunday shows that the
reticulocyte concentration is high
which demonstrates that bone marrow is
highly active in an attempt to replace
correct less than laws in a tubular
sight sound reflects the electrical
activity of the bone marrow and is very
useful in both the diagnosis of anemia
and in monitoring gold marrow response
to therapy
as you can see that the reticulated
paste account is also increase and this
increment is also available in the same
analysis it does not require any change
of the mode it does not require any
additional reagent it does not require
any coffee application the reticulated
cases are an integral part of the
reticulocyte analysis in eliminating
edge as we know that they have a much
shorter lifespan in the pencil
circulation
therefore they act as a muscle of mega
folio pointed activity in the bone
marrow which gives them better clinical
and diagnostic utility in this
particular case their possibilities of 7
etiology like hemolysis form Atacama
sightedness Kaluga microangiopathic
hemolytic anemia or bone marrow recovery
following chemotherapy
now looking to the scatterplot of this
case and comparing it with an all these
samples you can clearly see that the
reticulocyte population is more
prominent as compared to the
hematological a normal sample consistent
with the increased percentage
reticulocyte value detected parallelity
compared to the normal cloth the created
population is also extended along with
the XS showing the presence of large
platelets and the presence of the
increased number of reticulated pagelets
which we just saw with relatively high
for essence intensity both the size and
the increase are any content implies a
very immature basic population in this
case
you
in this one this is the same scatterplot
of the same pages but the scatterplot is
revealing the fluorescence versus the
size measurement the reticulated places
are measured using the same reagent that
is used for enumerated reticulocyte and
they are detected in the reticulocyte
challenge in energy it is possible to
have this parameter without any
additional application additional
reagents they does not impact the
turnaround time which is seen in many
other systems measuring reticulated
pitches to the proven clinical
usefulness in many patients is from the
site opinion of unknown etiology and for
monitoring bone marrow recovery after
chemotherapy or temple transplantation
studies also show that they have a role
in the etiology of the coronary artery
disease
not summarizing the presentation either
face that he tried to discuss better
conceptual overview of the lmd edge
advance map technology we try to discuss
the various analytical principles in
detail about the analysis of the red
blood cells white blood cells places and
reticulocyte and we discussed the six
basic cases to demonstrate the improved
accuracy of the cellular analysis of the
technology with higher efficiency and
confidence in results
all right I find you all for attending
the presentation today and I look
forward to answer your questions
you
thank you dr. Mukhtar for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you would
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for
okay let's get started
our first question is now this is a
two-part question how does advanced Maps
help in better platelet analysis using
the single channel approach while there
are manufacturers with dual technologies
and multiple reagents dyes of platelets
incorporated in systems do you have any
scientific study results or proof
sources
thank you very much for your question
and I think it's a very important
question to understand the advanced math
technology here particularly related to
platelets you are right that we said in
the presentation that advanced math
technology is helping in the better
fated analysis using a single channel
approach while there are other
manufacturers which have multiple
technologies using multiple reagents and
dyes so we explained already in the
presentation that how does it happen by
actually having a better analysis and
separation of the red blood cells from
the platelets in specific situations
when there are microcytic red blood
cells that are present in specific
situations when they are fragmented red
blood cells present by having multiple
angles of light scatter using the new
theory principle incorporating the
algorithm approach along with that we
are also using the fear-based analysis
of RBC's which reduces the orientation
effects of the RBC's that happens and
yes we have scientific data and true
sources which we have presented recently
also in some conferences in which we
have done the comparison of for the
platelet count obtained by a eliminate
cue system especially in the lower range
of platelets especially in cases where
they were microcytic RBC's or fragmented
our disease and we have data from those
studies which shows that when they are
platelets two counts of elimi t
particularly in the lower range of was
compared with the reference platelet
methodologies like NTC D 61 the the our
coefficient values are very good and
this data is already presented and can
be available on request from the medical
and scientific affairs division and this
data clearly shows that even
with one channel approach but with a
better or advanced version of technology
incorporating better algorithm of
culture we are able to achieve the
accuracy in the position of the
platelets of the lower ranges in
problematic samples as well in which it
is difficult to differentiate between
the red blood cells and platelets and
there the chance to report the wrong
place account or you have to perform the
smear disease
Moctar our next question how many events
for platelets and white blood cells are
counted for statistical validation
um this is a statistical question but I
have some information about it and I can
tell you normally in hematology analyzes
the number of events are mentioned in
the operations manual but as far as my
information is there for this analysis
for the red blood cells white blood
cells particular site the data which is
given to the algorithm for the analysis
we count approximately 750,000 either
and there are 16 bits of measurements
plus time spend time stamps per event
given to the algorithms
our next question how does the analyzer
differentiate between giant platelets
and let's save giant platelets and
platelet clumps
actually when you look at the analysis
of platelets there is a placement
clumped flag also and there is a volume
analysis available and there is a size
analysis available so the intermediate
there are various angles of Lights
captor that are there along with this
venice fluorescent technology as well so
there are many situations in which there
is a possibility to have giant platelets
or platelets lumps and the and the
scattergram actually clearly
differentiates and tells us about the
size and the volume of the platelets and
also get information about the
fluorescence intensity of the platelets
which is sometimes present in the
platelets that are immature and are of
large size
dr. mark our next question is two parts
is incorporating a single-channel
approach the only factor that reduces
turnaround in eliminate HQ and what are
some other elements that help in
automation of a system
well I think as well as a scientific
person that it is not only the single
channel approach which is the only
factor that reduces the turnaround time
in a little th cube because when you
look at the system overall it's a
complete solution of Hematology giving
complete automation to the laboratory
when you talk about automation in
reducing the turnaround time the
efficiency and the operational
productivity is measured by looking at
the path speed of the analyzer okay it
is one thing secondly by looking at the
design of the analyzer the reagent
management system where the variations
are duplicated they are concentrated
they are saving time there is less so
effort their best chances of errors for
the regions then there is caps
management which is also very important
to in a limite there is advanced apps
management system in place which is very
useful and it reduces the town a long
time and then when we look at the other
elements like IP based elements
providing the analyzer management system
elements in the reagent management in
the inventory management in the quality
management so these all elements combine
together then there is integration so
the slight difference trainer is
integrated and there is a bi-directional
track inside the system which helps in
also reducing the turnaround time so
it's a complete solution to the
laboratory looking at the dynamics of
reagent management system management
analysis providing better confidence in
results less number of reflux and repeat
testing and IP elements together to
provide the complete solution to the
laboratory introducing that a long time
in the results
now can capillary blood leak excuse me
can capillary blood be used in platelet
and white blood cell enumeration
see the capillary met when this question
comes normally I think it is asked
because it's about the sample volume
that is the reason that people ask this
question so we cannot use directly the
capacity tube but yes the small sample
up to 160 micro litre and particularly
in the closed mode can be used so it
term it helps a lot
even if the sample size is small sample
volume is small particularly in
Pediatrics or in such situations we are
getting a small getting a sample is
difficult so I think in a limited this
of this small sample volume and the
closed mode sampling to an extent there
helps in the analysis of short samples
can you explain to me a little bit more
about how optical flow cytometry
approach works better and only impedance
counting in separating red blood cells
and platelets giving any example
oh yes sir I think the best way to
explain this would be that mostly it is
coming the distinction is related to the
impedance technology the problem comes
in the differentiation between different
cell types based on their complexity and
this is the reason that they were three
power differential force and then when
we fight for differential training the
other technologies were included and
indicate in your question that so how it
separates better the red blood cells and
platelets I would say that in situations
where there are chances of having the
spurious results of platelets would be
better for in situations like having a
lot of spread vessel segments which can
be counted as platelets in shortened
clinical conditions for example like in
bonds there is a possibility that some
of the impedance based system might
count or enumerate the fragments as
cases and it will give rise to the
previous counts of faces right when we
will have a better analysis for from the
optical light scatter system based on
with fluorescence technology the
differentiation between the platelets
and Reds that cells which will be very
good giving accurate and precise results
of faith with without requiring reflex
testing without requiring a sneer review
thank you and we have so many great
questions coming in I just want to
remind our audience that any questions
that we do not have time for today and
those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
now our next question what is the
clinical importance of reticulated
platelets different methodologies are
used by different manufacturers is there
a stamp any standardization
reticulated platelets are available in
some of the limit ology analyzers so
these are basically immature papers that
are circulating in blood and they
reflect the legacy area voices the
activity of the bone marrow so it's a
very useful non-invasive analysis in
patients with homicidal mania in various
clinical situations to find the etiology
of the Samba cytokine iya and also the
bone marrow response to therapy as well
so regarding your question related to
the standardization up till now the
methodologies that are there in the
market to enumerate and identify the
reticulated Fitness are different so
there is no clear standardization that
exists in hematology analyzers related
to the methodology and some of the
studies do tell us about the method
based reference intervals of regulated
platelets so the laboratories have done
the reference interval studies and they
have validated their own reference
intervals in their specific patient
populations and this is how it is done
in the laboratories and where the
reticulated platelets have clinical
value yes the reticulated platelets have
proven to have chemical values in
situations when
when there is a response of the temple
transplant is required and they they are
useful in determining the been
monitoring the bone marrow recovery
after chemotherapy they also seem to
play a role in the etiology of coronary
artery disease in some studies and also
sometimes reticulated plated helps
clinicians in understanding the etiology
or thrombocytopenia and differentiating
it from autoimmune to other faces or
other causes of zombified experience so
it's a very important marker and it is
really useful for the clinicians in
certain clinical situations
dr. Mukhtar without a CD 61 how RP ICP
OCS resolved
P I see was it so POC what do you mean
by that
can you clarify something sure the
question submitted is without a CD 61
how RP IC or P a POC is resolved I think
this is related to the places and they
would like to know that the big box how
they are resolved without having CD 61
analysis in the analyzer well it is a
valid question to ask that how are we
sure about the results of the platelets
without having a reference methodology
and how do we resolve the problems of
deficit analysis or different weights
it's like but as I have explained
previously about the advancement of the
technology having a eight detectors
longer the fluorescence detector and
then using a transformation algorithm
there is a very clear separation between
the red blood cells and the platelets
addition in addition to this the
interfering substances or integrating
cells and how they remove the
interference is also explained in the
presentation in terms of the fragmented
red blood cells in terms of micro
particular cells how the RBC's are here
before the analysis how the intermediate
angles of light scatter are working to
differentiate itself from platelets then
by incorporating all these elements of
technology and methodology along with
the transformation and gore-ism approach
we are able to have a better surety and
position in the platelet results and
that we have demonstrated in the studies
that we have conducted in which we have
the data which clearly shows the
evidence of having a very good and
precise platelet count even as the lower
plate with the concentrations in the
abnormal conditions as well
to Mokhtar what is the nature of the
reticulocyte reagent
so regarding the complete reagent
constitutions yeah I I do not have the
complete reagent Constitution with me
that how the reticulocyte reagent is
constituted but the particular site
sorry agent 2 basically works with the
with the concept of having a specific
sure dye which is a patient died and the
purpose of it is to as I have explained
in the presentation the fluorescence so
this is there are nucleic acid staining
characteristics of the cell based on the
presence of the nuclear material in the
cells and the diet specifically stains
that material and then it image certain
signals of fluorescent signals that are
that are measured and based on the
measurement of the fluorescence signals
for particular sites which are immature
cells are separated from mature red
blood cells and similarly on the same
concept having the nuclear material in
the cells of like platelets when they
are immature they are separated from the
mature platelets and in this way we are
able to have within the same
reticulocyte analysis we are able to
have the immature red blood cells that
are reticulocyte we have immaturity
purified fraction that are highly
fluorescing reticulocyte because they
the their dye uptake is more and also
based on the size we separate them and
similarly we separate the mature plate
miss from the image of lipids based on
the size and tourism characteristics of
the cells so this is how the reagent
management system works for 80 psi
thank you now how are how jolly bodies
differentiated from MN RBC's
so and there there are problems with
Touhou jolly body analysis that have
seen in many analyzes this is true but I
would like to explain here the concept
of the nucleated are busy count that how
we are counting the nucleated RBC
counter the weg reagent actually
contains a nucleic acids electric source
and cationic dye that stains nucleic
acid and it flourishes after 525
nanometers and remove the cytoplasmic
membrane from the red blood cells so in
this way the nucleus the nucleated RBC
counter is available with the every WBC
differential result and regarding the
whole jolly bodies of course they also
have the training characteristics but
then the differentiates differentiation
is possible because the WBC analogical
approach step which clearly the
nucleated RBC is based on their sort and
crossing characteristics which is at a
certain wavelength and they are clearly
evident that these nuclear these are the
nucleated RBC's and they do not
interfere with the WBC analysis so the
other any other body is michael jolly
body so there are other cytoplasmic
inclusion bodies which can be present in
certain situations they are clearly
separated
from October on the RBC the red blood
cell and by the channel why are our red
blood cells IAS signal why is it bigger
than platelets IAS signal our red blood
cells don't have any nuclei and cell
content well I have to explain this in
the formal fall I would say in the
formal for me theory of light scatter so
there is a theory behind it will for the
measurement of the size and the volume
of the cells and there is a complete
statistical calculation of how to
improve the red blood cell and the
plated analysis based on the size and
volume measurements and which angles of
light scatter in which dimensions are
actually used to separate the red blood
cells and platelets if if this this
question requires more information I can
share the study behind it that why these
angles are smaller or why these angles
are bigger but this is a statistical
approach which has proven to be useful
and it is statistically tested in
various solutions of our disease in
which our BP was feared in which our
disease are not cleared in which our
disease will fix in which our disease
will not fix and then the dual angular
approach is used and these angles are
identified like that so there is there
is a science behind it and it is already
proven and we have references that can
be shared
now we are almost out of time we have
time for just a few more our next
question imaging based deep learning
algorithms are these days coming by a
lot of companies there are any
comparison wrt optical technique
techniques
I would say that yes it it is right that
amazing based deep learning algorithms
are coming up but a lot of companies and
we are hoping to have any comparisons
with respect to the optical techniques
for those methodologies so right now we
have some paracin which we have already
done with the some of the other
methodologies but we are also looking
forward to have for the collaboration
and to see whether there is a
possibility to conduct such a comparison
because it will be useful for us also to
do position and to see how this advanced
technology works better
most probably against the other
technology
okay and this will have to be our last
question what is the approximate manual
differential rate on alehna THQ from
experience
so see I have experience from different
regions of the world the rate of the
manual differential depends on the
patient population the type of hospital
the type of patients they see the type
of for clinical conditions they have in
their laboratory that is the pediatric
center on oncology center or hewmet all
of these centers or it is related to our
University Hospital but the data that I
have from Toshi care hospital in which
we have conducted such a study it tells
us that the manual differential rate
which was done before using an empty by
the Doshi care hospital which was
receiving around 400 samples a day with
all the specialities was reduced to 50%
of the existing rate so after using
energy they were able to reduce the
clear reviews by almost 50% so this is
what we have at the moment and by
looking at the analytical approach of
validity as you have clearly
demonstrated in the presentation that
the nucleated RBC's are not interfering
in the analysis the resistant RBC's are
not interfering in the analysis the the
[ __ ] pipes are not interfering in
analysis the platelets and the red blood
cells are clearly differentiated in
cases of for hemoglobin interferences
what is the analytical approach of this
analyser so looking at all these
elements it's very clear that and along
with the automation elephants for the
reflex testing for the rules of
validation the manual of slide review
rate chances of reduction are very high
that the laboratory will be able to
reduce the manual differential rates and
to give you some statistics which are
published the highest number of manual
review rates are due to the white blood
cell flagging so this is the topmost
region of the manual differential rates
and if you look at the analysis of
immunity we are providing WBC
differential and the total count by
removing all the interferences that may
impact to the white Breschel great so
it's very clear that the manual
differential review rate will be reduced
thank you dr. Mukhtar now do you have
any final comments for our audience
um I think go thank you very much first
of all for all of you to attend this
webinar and to make it making it
interactive so I think there is a lot of
there is a lot of more information
related to the technological advancement
which still needs to be discussed foil
energy we are in the initial phases and
quite confident all for having good to
an accurate result so so I thank all who
has attended this presentation and I
would be interested to get questions
because I would like to clarify the
doubts of various laboratorians and
scientist in the world related to the
technology and I would be pleased to
share and clarify information related to
the analytical approach of the cells in
order to have a clearer idea because
even when I while I was coming for the
webinar I was getting a lot of questions
with you which helped which which were
not which were related to the doubt on
the technology that how it is possible
the single journalist wrote the Lesley
agent complete automation so I think
there is a lot of room to get
information to people about it
and I'm open for all the questions and
would be pleased to answer even if they
record it from the email or they would
like to send it to us
thank you again dr. Mukhtar for your
time today and for your important
research we'd also like to thank lab
Rhodes and our sponsor Abba Diagnostics
for underwriting today's educational
webcast now before we go I like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions again that we did not have
time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by dr. Mukhtar via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration this webcast can be viewed
on-demand through May 2019 labradorite
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event I solve for
now and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye
okay